videogames are really hard and I'm not
I'm not just talking about eSports
either there are a ton of games out
there from casual to competitive that
take hours and hours of time skill and
precision to master but what if I told
you there was someone out there
mastering those games with a severe
disadvantage what if I told you there
was someone beating some of the hardest
games out there with just his chin and
he never had a choice in the matter
[Music]
before I tell you the story of one of
the most incredible streamers on Twitch
I want to hear from you if you like
these mini profiles we do on streamers
like this video subscribe to the channel
and let us up know in the comments who
you want to see us do a profile on next
look i've sat here many times and talk
to you about twitch about the most
popular streamers and drama and
everything the platform has to offer but
no story has quite blown me away quite
like this one
meet handi-capable 1 or Sean Cahill as
he's known offline the streamer who's
beat the kind of games that make us all
rage like Dark Souls 3 and jump King
except he did it with his chin on
February 11th Cahill made headlines by
beating one of the hardest bosses in
Dark Souls 3 slave night Gale a lot of
people refer to Gale as sort of the
final boss of the entire Dark Soul
series this guy takes [ __ ] hours to
beat yes
that took way too long holy [ __ ] that's
it wait you know I took like 10 plus
hours and while beating that difficult
boss made a bunch of headlines and
resulted in a bunch of growth for Cahill
online
he's also beat the other two games in
the dark souls franchise and a difficult
platformer called jump King in the last
few months on Street yes we did it
I can breathe that was the hardest game
I've ever played no like the next stop
for him is cuphead another platformer
shoot him up that he says is much more
difficult for him than Dark Souls for me
at least coca is harder
just cuz the whole time that you're
playing it's very demanding for me I
have to breathe in between since I don't
breathe them alone I have a breathing
machine so I have to take breaths
whenever there's downtime but for cahill
using his chin isn't a way to display
how good he is at games he doesn't have
a choice in the matter he suffers from a
disability called Duchenne muscular
dystrophy and to learn more about how
he's become so good at these games
without using the majority of his body
well we asked him so I have a muscular
dystrophy and it affects all my muscles
in my body so I would say I'm like
practically paralyzed because I can't
really move my arms and legs but I can
feel everything and my head I can barely
move I can lose my chin really well
Cahill's disability is progressive so
when he was young he was able to play
games just fine with his hands but as
he's gotten older its worsened I started
feeling it more in high school I noticed
I couldn't really hold the controllers
that will or play as well as others kids
there's a time I think in college I
didn't play much video games at all by
high school he knew that if he wanted to
continue to play games like he did when
he was young he would have to
manufacture a controller or a system
that would allow him to do so and so he
did he went out and he found a bunch of
controllers and pads that allowed him to
continue to play games even as his
disability got worse yeah it's kind of
like an evolution of different things
I started playing League of Legends and
that required the mouse but also the
keys to like do your spells and stuff so
we had like
a bendable arm that had like a halo but
we're neuron my head-to-head switches on
it so I would have I had on the
different switches to cast my different
spells I realized League of Legends too
hard for me I'd get you angry playing
that games man I can't even execute a
well time flash and this guy is trying
to do it with his head and now he's
moved to an Xbox controller using
special software to map keys to the
controller so I don't actually use the
controllers buttons I have the left
joystick for movement in dodging and
then I use the d-pad for some buttons
and the right joystick for some buttons
okay so like I said when he was younger
his condition got worse and worse and he
had to find ways to continue to play
games and once he did that he decided to
take on some of the most difficult games
ever and this is where frustrating games
like Dark Souls cuphead and jump King
come in these are games that while
obviously fun and well designed are
often talked about as hard for the sake
of heart you need to log hours and hours
to beat them at the highest difficulty
and let me tell you they are frustrating
as hell I mean there are literal
competitive community is designed around
beating these games in increasingly
difficult ways and once cahill started
to master his new setup he decided to
stream these games well i mean i was
always watching with twitch streamers i
felt like i could always do it but I
just didn't have well I didn't have the
internet wired internet so I didn't
really pursue it but I eventually since
I don't work and I have a lot of free
time I thought eventually I'll just give
it a try and see how it goes and when it
comes to choosing the games themselves
he actually focuses on what is hardest
that's the theme of his champ him
overcoming the obstacle of these
massively hard games while also
obviously overcoming his own obstacles
with that said speaking to Cahill
actually gave us some insight into how
he's uniquely well fit for these games
he says that the patience he's developed
through just living his everyday life
has really helped him beat these games
that require a ton of patience to be
good at and he said playing these games
it offers the kind of freedom that he
just doesn't always have in his everyday
life but as you might imagine starting
up a stream didn't come with some risk
for
are some non physical difficulties that
come with this gig to the obvious risks
of being bullied or tokenized or
trivialized but he says as long as his
viewers are positive he's happy I mean I
used to feel that way about things like
that
retinol there I see that maybe they
don't know as a disabled persons they
would necessarily know how to react to
something like that as long as they're
being positive about it I don't see
Cahill did have one bone to pick though
he says that right now big game
developers simply do not make their
games accessible enough he often finds
that there are hiccups integrating his
software with new games that start up in
fact he says he could hardly play
console games at all right now due to
the lack of accessibility
it feels currently a lot of big-name
developers of their games are accessible
yeah this is especially true for like
shooter games so my favorite game series
is halo and because my disability now I
can't play halo anymore and if they
added a feature where it's do what all
the console games needs to do for
shooters like ever it would kind of like
a sticky game kind of I feel like
Microsoft might be the only one because
also their games are coming to PC as
well it kind of allows me to play their
games so that means I might be able to
give the new Halo game a try I don't
know it's it seems fun like I obviously
I like I like the idea of games like
that where I where it's like kind of
like puzzle slash skill where you're
like trying to figure out all of the
ways to like get past these extremely
difficult tasks that sort of thing I
know a couple couple two three things
about a war of attrition you know yeah
yeah forever that's that's the that's
the the crux of how to how to be good at
magic gathering you two for one your
opponent attrition